first the 2024 election year is less
than a year away Democrats they are
running scared and in all likelihood yep
80-year-old Joe Biden will be the
party's nominee Democrats then will be
forced to face a pretty uncomfortable
truth and that is that Joe has massive
problems and not just his declining
physical and cognitive health or his
vast policy failures no tonight the
corruption claims against the president
and his family they are very very real
multiple House and Senate investigations
have already detailed what is an
extensive money Trail all exposing the
flow of foreign cash right into Biden
family bank accounts now according to
multiple Witnesses and whistleblowers
emails and texts the bidens were selling
access and influence to Joe Biden and
according to his own son Hunter the big
guy his father was taking a cut now of
course we knew about this apparent
corruption well before the 2020 election
but now you know what the left the media
mob they could no longer censor the
truth big Tech remember they were
humiliated and Twitter or X well that's
now under new ownership now the federal
government includes Bad actors in the
FBI the doj and the CIA they were all
exposed in terms of being politicized
and weaponized and during testimony well
an FBI official was forced to admit that
Hunter's laptop was in fact very
authentic and they knew it but yet they
were warning big tech companies oh you
might be a victim of a misinformation
campaign and it might be about Hunter
and Joe Biden now all in an effort to
seem fair Biden's doj well looking for a
fall guy or a sacrificial lamb someone
who can Shield the President Joe Biden
from charges while taking all the blame
now according to even fake news CNN
Hunter has real cause for concern
tonight take a look how significant La
do you think this is it's bad news for
Hunter Biden anyway you slice this I
mean let's remember he already has a
pending indictment in the federal
district court in Delaware for the
Firearms related charges and now he
potentially is looking at a second
indictment out of California and if we
think about the potential tax charges
here it's important to keep in mind when
Hunter Biden went into court a few
months ago with doj they had a deal that
he was going to plead guilty to
misdemeanor tax offenses and they agreed
doj and Hunter Biden agreed that he had
failed to pay over a million dollars in
income taxes
that he owed so assuming which I think
is a fair assumption that doj has
evidence of that that feels like the
minimum charges he may face it may get
worse now remember after attempting to
let Hunter go away scott-free without
any charges and letting serious tax
violations expire and pass the statute
of limitations and after that egregious
attempt at that sweetheart plea deal
well that failed in spectacular fashion
well now the doj they're kind of out of
options and they are running dangerously
low on credibility so now Hunter is in
big trouble but it's not really about
Hunter is it it's about his dad now
nothing that could connect his misdeeds
to the big guy well that evidence is
growing by the day and for example we
have an attorney general his name is
Merck Garland he has a weaponized doj
the president's adult son is currently
facing felony gun charges however tax
indictments could very soon be on the
horizon you just heard it from even a
pro Biden CNN quote attorney a grand
jury now in California has been
impaneled remember the whole controversy
over David Weiss he said he didn't have
authority to charge in places uh like
Washington DC in California Merck arand
said he did have it now he's a special
counsel however during the barisma years
well guess what those are the tax years
that they allowed to expire the statute
of limitations anyway prosecutors now
have called numerous Witnesses including
Hunters uncle and occasional business
associate Joe's brother Jim Biden now I
don't know what's going to become of all
of this tax case but we do know that
Hunter's finances are shady to say the
least now despite making millions of
dollars from the Biden brand I doubt it
was Hunter the Biden brand I'm sure it
was pops the Biden brand Hunter
regularly had trouble making ends meet
but in 2020 when Joe became the
Democratic nominee well according to
justnews.com
many of Hunter's Financial woses
vanished thanks to of course the
generosity from wealthy Democratic
donors and a name that keeps coming up
is a guy by the name of Kevin Morris so
according to a new report investigation
by justnews.com editor and chief John
Solomon he details how Hunter collected
$6 million since his father began
running for president not from one
person but from a number of people again
all people that supported Joe Biden
they're saying much of this may have
come from Kevin Morris so how did Hunter
spend this money well unquote five
figure monthly rents at a California
home large child support payments some
travel many legal bills Federal and
local tax debts totaling more than $2
million where why does Hunter have all
these rich friends just willing to give
him money in a statement at
justthenews.com well a lawyer for Kevin
Mars the guy whose name keeps coming up
a potential source for these claims
accusing the the source of quote a
campaign of harassment against Mr moris
we'll find out time will tell the
statement continues quote this
individual has only disclosed certain
information to cause Mr Morris public
embarrassment and may have outright
misrepresented facts and statements
about Mr Morris as part of his this
campaign of quote harassment not sure
what this means who's harassing Mr
Morris we don't know know meanwhile John
Solomon reporting that no one not even
Joe Biden's brother Jim seemed to know
why this individual and others were
potentially giving Hunter so much money
but now of course house investigators
they would like to know more they have
now requested an interview from the
attorney who they say may have
bankrolled Hunter's lifestyle for years
so is this going to have any
implications for Hunter's tax case or
Joe Biden himself hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else